rasaan beethoven we understand that
edmund morris is going to be playing
piano during his presentation we are
bringing you eight hours of coverage
live coverage of today's events and
bringing you a live talk with Pulitzer
Prize winning author Doris Kearns
Goodwin a little bit later she'll
discuss her book the team of rivals
about Abraham Lincoln
after that Dora Bush cooked the sister
of president george w bush shall be
introduced by her brother Florida
Governor Jeb Bush and today's events at
miami-dade College expected to draw
hundreds of thousands of visitors as I
said 270 authors some 250 exhibitors
fair began back in 1984 true about
25,000 people then hundreds of thousands
are expected during this weekend
all right we got you Diane get up
well you got a space get more people
and we're back live now preparing to
bring you a panel on writing biography
it'll feature author journalist and
critic Christopher Hitchens
novelist and National Book Award
finalists Francine prose and Pulitzer
prize-winning biographer edmund morris
this panel is one of many that are part
of this year's 23rd annual Miami Book
Fair International
once again we're preparing you to listen
to a biography panel with author
journalist and critic Christopher
Hitchens novelist and National Book
Award finalist Francine prose and
Pulitzer prize-winning biographer edmund
morris a little bit later during our
live coverage of Miami Book Fair
International will have Pulitzer Prize
winning author Doris Kearns Goodwin
she'll discuss Abraham Lincoln and her
book the team of rivals and after that
Doris Bush adoro Bush cook the sister of
president george w bush she will be
introduced by her brother Florida
Governor Jeb Bush live coverage I of
Miami Book Fair international continuing
here on book TV on c-span too
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
I'm very pleased to see you all here for
what's going to prove to be quite an
interesting presentation while we were
organizing you saw us bring out the
piano and we hope we'll have a little
musical interlude I want to ask you to
be sure that we don't have any musical
interlude from the audience so please
turn off your cell phones beepers
whatever else makes noise and I hope
that you've enjoyed the Faire so far
it's a wonderful wonderful Faire this is
our 23rd year I don't want to say best I
just want to say we're maturing
beautifully it is my pleasure to
introduce a real friend of the fair
James
Atlas of Atlas books will present our
next authors thank you
they're shy they'll be here with that
I promised I've never done this before
yeah first of all I want to say I I want
to thank Mitchell Kaplan for putting
together this astonishing astonishing we
were talking before all the writers who
hang around waiting to go on in the
green room about how much we love to
come here and we've all managed to
wangle invitations year after year now
I told Mitch I just have to come every
year until the end of eternity and we
got to sit around and and visit among
ourselves before going out to speak to
this very appreciative public which
always amazes me there was an article in
The Herald in the Miami Herald this
morning I don't know if you saw it all
about the end of literature by some very
crabby guy who I hope isn't in the
audience and who wrote for The Herald
for many years about the literature is
no longer important and no longer
matters but an audience like this
disproves it and so I'm very grateful to
have you here
it's hard to talk about this to
introduce this these panelists in a
regular way with all their achievements
enumerated because first of all if I did
that we'd be here for the better part of
the hour while I was just reciting their
books and also I know them so well I've
known them for as long as I can remember
especially Francine who published her
first novel due to the pious when she
was barely out of college and she was
the first novelist I ever knew first
real novelist and has been writing
steadily ever since disproving the idea
that you can't be but perhaps
single-handedly disproving the idea that
you can't be a person of letters in
America because over the West I hate to
say this 30-some years Francine has
written
many novels nonfiction the most recent
book just out which was on the
bestseller list called reading like a
writer and its title makes it very clear
what it's about and journalism essays
and reviews and I was just saying to her
before she's never written anything as a
hack it's all excellent top-flight
literary work and she said the reason
for that is that she she refused an
invitation from viced magazine to write
for them and so I also know them because
I'm the publisher of their most recent
books and I see these books arrive at a
certain point and there are grey boxes
I'm always amazed these are always
professionals they turn in their books
on time and they're excellent with
edmund morris we talked about this book
on beethoven for quite a few years as i
recall and he is of course famous as a
presidential biographer but he had a
great passion for music and had always
wanted to write about beethoven nearly
became if i'm correct a concert pianist
do you probably regret that you ended up
as a writer instead it's a terrible way
to make a living and and so finally the
moment came when i invited him to write
this book and he drew upon a lifetime of
thinking about music thinking about
beethoven and wrote of really lovely
book and christopher hitchens is well
he's christopher hitchens
for those of you who watch TV ever or
read a magazine ever or frequent any
section of any bookstore you'll know his
work last time i was on a panel with you
it was about Saul Bellow hit and you got
into a huge argument with Cynthia osek
about Israel so and didn't say anything
about bail although I
stick to the topic today the topic is
biography and Christopher has his next
book coming out should be very bland and
uncontroversial God is not great so
we'll see that in May if I could just
say embarassingly a few promotional
words about this series the eminent
lives is a series of short biographies
by distinguished writers on great
canonical figures in history religious
cultural literary political and it's the
sequel to the penguin lives that I
started a decade ago or so it has
emerged as popular form at least among
writers and actually among readers too
I'm glad to say because while taking a
break from the monolithic works that
they write they're encouraged to write a
short book of 40 or 50 thousand words
that just engages them in a very
different way and that that brings that
enables them to write about what I would
call an obsession of theirs it comes
very easily to them when I ran into
Francine at a at a Book Fair somewhere
when I was just starting this series I
said who would you like to write about
it and without any hesitation she said
Caravaggio and it was the same with
Edmond and Beethoven and with
Christopher as he just reminded me I
came up with the idea of stature for
some reason and he wasn't too keen on
that and then I came up with the idea of
Jefferson and that seemed to be just
right for him so and he did a marvelous
book in the space of some months I don't
quite know how just if I could say one
more word about these short biography
it's a it's a form that emerges out of a
tradition of English literature that
begins with Samuel Johnson's wives of
the poets and continues on through
written Strachey's eminent Victorians
also the book that I was reading when I
thought up this idea when I was on page
a thousand of my own biography of Saul
Bellow thought there's got to be some
other way to do this as reading a short
biography by Macaulay on Boswell and
it's a very congenial form so I'd like
to begin by asking each of you what the
experience was like of writing a short
biography and what it was that impelled
you to this subject and then we can
focus on some other issues related to
biography so I'm gonna sit down and well
I just wondered if it wouldn't be a good
moment to say all the things that I
would have meant to say about Saul
Bellow remember no I can remember what I
fully intended to say well I think it is
in fact Lord Byron who says of this man
of species the span of a human life is
it is like the summer of a dormouse and
one of the things I find reading most
biographies they're not in writing the
one I did is is the discovery that
you're bound to make of how few years in
most people's lives are worth paying any
attention to how many of them are well
spent or interesting or rewarding either
for them or for anybody else but the
Dormouse problem doesn't come up in the
case of our third president Thomas
Jefferson because and it also this is an
additional reason why I was a very
challenging project he lived to be
whatever 80s you know for more than more
than 20 years nearly 25 continuously he
was actually in power once he goes off
to be our minister in Paris
until the end of his second term as
president he's almost permanently at the
very center of of power that's not true
of George Washington for example it's
not true of Abraham Lincoln it's not
true of Franklin Delano Roosevelt to
have this extraordinary span of time at
the head of the nation's affairs and
that's after he's been governor of
Virginia author of the Declaration of
Independence and is before he does the
Jefferson Bible which if you don't know
I'll just tell you
consists of taking the New Testament in
one hand and a razor blade in another
and cutting out all the bits that are
either wicked or fanciful or stupid or
incredible or mythological or absurd or
contradictory leaving you with a very
slender book which you can still get for
free from the Unitarian Church but which
used to be given to all members of
Congress as a present the first day they
showed up for work so it's an
extraordinary life and the job of car of
condensation was extremely difficult for
me but very fascinating because the
reason I said yes to Jim as soon as he
asked me was well of course I will
because whatever else one is writing
about one is always writing about Thomas
Jefferson at least when you're writing
about the United States which is the
great subject for any writer you're
writing about him because of nation
building because of Constitution writing
because of their concept of America as
an empire because of American
expansionism because of the idea of
democracy and of course because of the
theory and practice of slavery and
because of the wall of separation
between church and state every any time
you ought we care to speak or choose to
die late on any of these topics where
we're talking about Thomas Jefferson and
thus I would I decide I would call the
book what the author of America in that
America is itself a written work in
progress is based on written documents
which are subject to revision and are
and have been very importantly and very
dramatically revised and that's the
other reason it
why America is such a great subject for
a writer because it's it's a written and
a right early enterprise to begin with
um I shouldn't trust us much more on the
answers of first question so to say one
thing I think maybe conceivably to who
one is last time I did a panel on this
Michael quarter was among was of the
company he said here's one thing about
refer must never do he was never say
about some contingency or some
conjuncture well at this moment
so-and-so must have thought or must have
felt or may never do that never make
that assumption you're not entitled to
it you don't know that you shouldn't
pretend that you do even if you think
you know more about the subject than
anybody else and I I heartily concurred
and I thought it was completely right
I'd heard the thought before had the
thought myself except that I realized
that when Thomas Jefferson saw Sally
Hemings not for the first time because
she was a little girl but for the second
time when she showed up in her early
teens in France I think he thought and
to himself and said to himself possibly
for the first and only time there is a
God aside from that I think my my
summary injunction would be about the
the letter to the Baptist's of jamberry
Connecticut in which the wall of
separation is first suggested because
they wanted protection by the way guests
from whom the Baptist's of Danbury
Connecticut who do they want protection
from the Congregationalists of Danbury
Connecticut that's why a secular state
is necessary to guarantee religious
pluralism so I'll just end by saying mr.
Jefferson build up that wall thank you
edmond on you next well I must say I
identify with Thomas Jefferson and Sally
Hemings because this morning in the
elevator
meg tilly spoke to me and I knew without
doubt that there contrary to what
Christopher will be saying and he's a
forthcoming book there is a god I fell
in love with her when I first saw The
Big Chill 15 20 years ago and she's as
beautiful now as she was then and she's
appearing I believe at this festival at
two o'clock this afternoon so that's
made the journey worthwhile if nothing
else
Jim passed over rather briefly the
protracted negotiations which produced
my little biography of Beethoven
he indeed came to me and said do you
want to write one of these short
biographies and I said yes and I'd
rather like to do one about Ludwig van
Beethoven he said well it's going to be
a difficult sell you know to my backers
because books on composers don't do all
that well and he went to talk to his
backers and surely enough he came back
and said I'm sorry they don't want to do
it he said do you want to do anyone else
I said oh all right how about Ingmar
Bergman he said when he's kind of
Swedish sort of passe so I said all
right I'll do evening war what about
that it's kind of English so I walked
off in a huff and a year later he came
back he said you still want to do better
I said yes please
so he hold out this contract for 250
dollars and
unscrewed his fountain pen he said now
before I sign it what will the subtitle
be Sid subtitle are you kidding
Beethoven needs a subtitle he said well
it's the format of the series we got to
have a subtitle well I needed the 250
bucks so I said all right what about
Beethoven death but not dumb
which for a moment I think he took
seriously but we compromised eventually
on Beethoven the universal composer I
called him the universal composer
because of all the great composers
Beethoven is the only one whose
popularity has increased right from the
moment he was first recognized as a
composer of the first quality in Vienna
in the late 18th century Beethoven's
Fame grew and grew and grew through his
own lifetime he lived just 56 years and
it continued to mushroom after his death
unlike Johann Sebastian Bach who was
largely forgotten after his death for
half a century
unlike Mozart who was pretty fired by
the Victorians and miniaturised unlike
all the other great composers one can
think of Beethoven's reputation has
continued to increase at a proportionate
rate ever since his death in 1827 last
year the BBC radio third programme in
Britain for the first time in its
history
did a two-week wall-to-wall 24 hour a
day symposium on Beethoven playing all
his works interspersing lectures and
readings and during the course of this
Beethoven fortnight as they called it
they're reviving the breed beautiful old
English were at fortnight they offered
free downloads of any Beethoven symphony
to any listener around the world and
they got one and a half million
downloads most of which came in from
Asia which proves I think that Beethoven
speaks loudly more loudly now than he
has ever done in the past and the
universal quality that speaks to us that
speaks to the Chinese that speaks to
Africans is particularly vital now
because we live in a world which seems
to be increasingly a world consisting of
chaos to use a phrase of even was it is
chaos that shrieks about our ears and in
the chaotic times such as the one we
live in Beethoven's philosophy of
struggle all his great works all his
works synthesize chaotic elements bring
them together with the superhuman
strength pull them apart forced them
together again into a resolution at the
climax of the work which seems to be
elemental indestructible
Beethoven speaks to us in this
constructive language more powerfully
today than ever before
a case in point even though it's
somewhat dated occurs in the prologue to
my book where I used an incident in
February of 1978 I happen to be up at
Harvard researching my book on Theodore
Roosevelt when Massachusetts disappeared
under the worst blizzard in its history
they still talk about it to this day for
three or four days the entire state and
most of the Northeast was inundated in a
wait of snow the whole state was
paralyzed no light no power no food no
movement no sound and on the third day
of this paralysis the Sun finally came
out and students emerged from the
buildings in Harvard Yard and began to
ski across the six-foot deposit of snow
and the Sun was shining in the air was
bright I stood up to my hips in snow
watching this return of life and some
anonymous person threw open the windows
of his
dorm room put a pair of stereo speakers
on the windowsill and blast it out into
the sunshine the finale of Beethoven's
fifth symphony and everybody stood
transfixed for the ten minutes that this
music lasted and when it ended with 48
thunderclaps of c-major quite a few of
us were crying it just seemed I don't
know what possessed this person to play
that music but nothing so perfectly
expressed the feeling we all shared look
we have come through we were buried we
have emerged
now Edmund I don't dispute your account
of what actually happened I can't
because it's true but the the problem is
that it shows me how difficult it is to
know or remember anything about anyone
or any event that happened which is a
real viability for a biographer and but
I'm sure but everything you did say was
was true and I've managed to avoid that
into I suggested or came to Edmund and
asked him who he want to do and he said
Beethoven and that was the cat and it's
kind of easier that's why I like these
short biographies you're just gonna
leave out all the things that you forgot
or that traumatized you or that you
don't want to write about soon one of
the reasons that I was drawn to the form
of a short biography or to be I guess
you could say a short biographer was
that I have many close friends Jim
included who were her long biographers
and and I saw over the years how they
suffered the years it took the
disenchantment the work the doubts and
and above all what I noticed and and Jim
may be an exception was was how rarely
by the end of the project their
enthusiasm and their affection for their
subject had persisted through the
project often they just hated the person
they were writing about by the end of
the biography and I would have hated for
that to happen for me with Caravaggio
because he is and was and I am happy to
say continues to be my favorite painter
I mean I came to the book out of great
passion for Caravaggio's work and and
also as I noticed when I would go to see
museums here and churches in Europe
there were always crowds in front of his
paintings and I began to realize that
that passion was shared and that he
seemed to me an extremely modern painter
since
has told his celebrity proximity story
I'll tell mine which was I gave a talk
about Caravaggio at the Metropolitan
Museum about six months ago and the
actor who played Furio and The Sopranos
was there and came and got his book
signed and and said that I'd done a very
good portrait of Naples from where he
came and I thought that's it I can just
quit right now the other thing about
Caravaggio was that was that he seemed
to me a perfect subject for a brief life
because he had such a brief life himself
he only lived to be 39 years old and it
was an it was a life that was perfect
for a novelist to write about I mean he
was not only a genius and a great artist
but he was also a criminal and a
murderer and he was he committed a
murder several years four years before
he died and then was on the run for the
last four years of his life and his life
was the most dramatic I mean just
telling the story of his life was was
incredibly satisfying for a novelist
just I'll conclude by telling you that a
story that to me illustrates the the
extent to which my affection for
Caravaggio continued to the end and
through the end of the project about a
year ago I was in Rome and at a dinner
party and it was a very long dinner
party at which many many bottles of wine
were drunk and and and the other guests
were all Russian painters so as you can
imagine after the wine then about a la
vodka was suddenly produced in tequila
and so forth which may explain why at
some point I found myself having a
conversation with a friend of mine a
Russian painter about which was the
greater artist Mel Gibson or Caravaggio
and my friend Matt Fae said okay I'll
give you this
he said Mel Gibson was a bad artist and
Caravaggio was a great artist but they
were both interested in violence and and
I kind of got on my high horse and I
said yes well Mel Gibson was in favor of
capital punishment and Caravaggio was
not and my friend said yes but Mel
Gibson didn't actually kill somebody
and Caravaggio did and I said he did I'd
written the book I knew perfectly well
that he did I had written in detail
about the murder but by then still my
love for Caravaggio was so intense that
the fact that he was a murderer had just
somehow gone out of my mind
fancy in regard to your comment about
how one ends up hating one's subject if
you write a very long
biography let me just say as a as the
perpetrator of one of these books that
if you spend 12 hours a day for 10 years
with your subject which is far in excess
of what you spend with even your child
or your spouse you end up having a real
problem no one should know anyone that
well I ability but you know one thing I
want to discuss was the relationship of
the biographer to the subject
I was talking to Edmund that the while
we were waiting to go on here this
morning about his biography of Regan
which i think is just a fantastic book
and was praising mightily and I'm I I
recall that there was a traumatic moment
when reviewers protested the fact that
Edmund had put in a fictional character
to this otherwise incredibly vivid non
fictional narrative and he said we are
all biographers put in this fictional
character only he did it explicitly and
I found that fascinating I wonder if you
could expand Shaitaan that a little bit
because what you meant of course was
that we that the biographer has a point
of view whether it's acknowledged or not
in a very strong point of view
well the biographer does in effect
become
an observer of a participant in the life
of his or her subject as Francine just
indicated sometimes the relationship
becomes quasi amorous not in my case
sometimes it's quite the contrary the
the the relationship becomes so fraught
as with the example of lawrence thompson
and robert frost where during the course
of three volumes he discovered that this
man he worshiped so much was a monster
and then the more when he read Frost's
letters the more he detested him so the
book the volume the third volume becomes
a diatribe which is almost unreadable
the emotional question had become so
high so we all become involved in the
lives of our subjects and the idea of
biographical stance is one of mild
affection love is dangerous hatred is
poisonous but some affection mild
affection should be there otherwise it's
not much fun to spend seven or fourteen
years in the company of this person also
going through the letters of
interviewing the children of studying
the the life of listening to the
recordings of this person one becomes
almost a participant in the life I
happen to be a participant in Reagan's
life in the sense that I was able to go
to the White House during his presidency
and be with him and interview him and
observe him and follow him around and I
developed a closeness of POV of
the point of view that was so close that
I began to feel the absence of that
closeness when I went back to earlier
parts of his life when I wasn't actually
there so I decided to do to make
explicit what is implicit in all
biographies and
is put my self in the form of a
fictitious observer into Reagan's early
life a person of whom he was always
unaware was Reagan tended to be of
everybody and preserved this closeness
of you all the way through it was a
technique that I realized would be
controversial and insert he did it
proved to be so but I do think that it
was an honest device and I'm kind of
encouraged to notice that other writers
have have have moved in similar
directions since for example Andrew
Motion who is the poet laureate of Great
Britain after Dutch was published came
out of the book on Thomas Wainwright the
Romantic poet who was involved in a
murder case and was transported to
Australia and remotion wrote this very
scholarly book as an autobiography it's
written in Wainwright's own voice and
the end of every chapter and remotion
gets into a debate with his narrator so
it's a post modernist technique that I
think is honest and exciting and I think
it'll be followed by more such
experiments yes you know Peter Ackroyd
and his biography of Dickens where he
emulates Dickens and converses with
Dickens and it's it's another way of
approaching the subject in some ways
enviable because you can just make it up
Christopher well I think it's um it's
not so necessary even to effect
neutrality for example at Thomas Carlyle
when he set out to do Cromwell was
self-consciously trying to do a rescue
operation on a reputation he said
dragging him out as he put it from
underneath a heap of dead dogs and
carrion in order to so dust him down and
dispel this terrible a cloud of slander
that had accumulated and I think in
Isaac deutsches wonderful three volume
iboga fee of leon trotsky he I'm fairly
sure he starts by saying he wants to do
for Trotsky what what Carlisle did for
Cromwell and as long as this is openly
admitted I think that's perfectly fine I
only know it from the opposite
standpoint because one of the reasons I
said no to your proposal about Thatcher
was that it had when young had a very
very brief and very unsatisfactory
sexual encounter with her but I wasn't
completely certain that this wouldn't
sub taint the whole thing but the other
time that I had to do a study of a
person there's a living one
it wasn't exactly a biography of did see
an extended political profile and and
inquiry into the life and indeed the
crimes of Henry Kissinger and by the
time I was finished with that I felt as
if I got gangrene I can tell you if you
if you sir just be get up in the morning
with Henry and then go to bed still
thinking about him over an extended
period it will make you sick and when
people come to me and ask me to sign the
book and say they want to read all they
have read I said what did it make you
feel ill that's my test for this book
have I passed on at least some of the
feeling of nausea and disgust and
usually yes I have managed to offload
some of it but it's written I must tell
you with a tone of perfect detachment
and neutrality you know it I didn't know
about that sir by the way that's
you know it occurs to me thinking about
our three biographers here that that
your subjects and by the way you've also
you wrote about Kissinger with distinct
antipathy but with great sympathy for
Orwell and Jefferson
two other subjects I have an answer now
to that the I used to get approached by
motherly ladies in bookstores when I did
signings and they would be worried and
they come up to me and say we know don't
you like anybody as if I was so secretly
unhappy and venting no no look I've
written always furry books about people
who I like you know I think is sweet
yeah but Christopher let's not forget
about Mother Teresa this is a guy who
did a teardown job on Mother Teresa
it's an easy target what else well I
said she's an easy target but you got I
didn't know this was gonna turn into a
sitcom here this morning feel like I
have Seinfeld up here but in any event
one of the things that interested me
about you're among the many things about
your biography of Jefferson was that you
have a great love affair with America
and have written many essays about that
and of course you you view this from the
perspective of an expatriate who has now
become an American citizen is that right
and so I always think that that there is
some very distinct vantage point of view
that enables one to as it were solve
problems solve issues Express issues in
your own life without being too
Freudian about it but but Francine's
subject is also very different from
anything you've written and Edmunds
emerges out of your your lifelong
passion for music it interests me that
you that you chose these subjects why
why is it what is the appeal of someone
who is so far in a way from your own
experience and yet answer is so deeply
two questions in your own life maybe you
could address that well it's true the
difference when one believes as I do
have come to believe that the American
Revolution is the only revolution left
the only ones still standing there
anyone with any life or vigor in it the
only one that could be emulated with
profit by another culture and other
people then it is very important to
understand what the theory of that
revolution was and it's best articulated
by well by Thomas Jefferson
and by my next subject traumas Payne who
was a great Englishman as well as a
great American that's the that's really
what fascinated me about them and then
of course you have to try and see it
from the point of view that they they
did which is they were the first people
really we know about ever in history to
be a to be given a new canvas with which
to start the contest due to tow said to
Thomas Jefferson that she hugely envied
him because the revolutionaries in
France have this audience table of a
misery and poverty and hatred and
repression and exploitation that they
had to clear and the United States
revolutionaries didn't have that they
could begin de novo and that was that
was the wonderful refreshment of the
American Revolution then of course if
you did say this someone's going to ask
you well what in that case what about
slavery what about if you like the
original sin or the the original stain
and I suppose the saddest thing for me
writing about the book writing the book
writing about Jefferson I mean because
of course I knew all that was that bad
as it was it was much worse than I had
realized in that not only does Jefferson
fail to abolish slavery in fact he
decides to postpone the whole idea of
abolition from reasons that must have
seemed realistic enough to him he more
or less consciously gifts this horrible
legacy to the next generation I had
thought that that was roughly as bad as
it was and he he kept it going he missed
the chance to abortion he missed the
chance to not extend it to the Louisiana
territories the purchase of which was
his idea and Thomas Paine's idea but
what I hadn't appreciated was that he
extended and deepened the whole of
slavery as well he made certain that it
went into the New Territories over the
objections of people like pain and
Barlow by the way not to get carried
away with this but the thing you'll
sometimes told is you mustn't judge by
contemporary standards biographer
mustn't impose as it were our prejudices
or our wisdoms on the past I often think
that some that's false friendship
an advice as piece of advice because
there were people like Joel Barlow and
Thomas Paine who thought exactly about
slavery as we like to think we do and
who tried to say to Jefferson don't do
this mr. president we we can begin again
with Louisiana without this terrible
system but by agreeing to do it he made
sure absolutely sure not just that there
would be a protracting of the
institution and a deepening an extension
of it he made certain there would be a
civil war about it and I hadn't really
appreciated that the situation had been
as grave as that now but it but he he
was a slave owner but he was not a
murderer
so unlike Caravaggio who you you had to
overlook this minor character in the
back of my mind or the front of my mind
the whole time I was writing about
Caravaggio it was the kind of the larger
abstract question of of why certain
works of art endure and and how certain
works of art continued to speak to us
over time and centuries so a particular
problem writing about Caravaggio is that
so little was known about his life I
mean he left no journals he left no
letters he left no preparatory drawings
and most of what we know about
Caravaggio in fact comes to us through
police reports court desert depositions
complaints of his neighbors and so forth
so so really all I could do or what I
mainly did was look at the paintings and
I thought the longer I look at these
paintings and the harder I think about
these paintings the more I'm going to
know about Caravaggio and in fact
there's a very kind of intimate
communication with the painter that that
does occur aided by the fact that he
that he put self-portraits into so many
of his paintings and when you look at at
you know the great famous David with the
head of Goliath which was one of his
final paintings and he's holding the
young David is holding the head of glass
and in fact it's a double self-portrait
it's the it's the young Caravaggio and
the the old wounded Caravaggio and if
you look at that
picture long enough I think that you do
figure out certain things about its
creator and and those were things I
tried to put into the book yeah that and
Edmond you also stressed the sense of of
universality and I wonder if it's it's a
virtual requirement of biography that
the subject have that kind of ranged
that you really are able to express
through your subject the same kinds of
Universal feelings that a painter would
or a composer well all men contain
multitudes I think it's quite possible
in fact it's often been proven that you
can write a biography of the highest
literary in scholarly quality about
somebody who was not Universal somebody
who might be indeed rather minor for
example aj simon's book the quest for
Corvo a book which is about the pursuit
of the recovery of an almost forgotten
minor figure in British literary history
and turned out to be one most
fascinating biographies ever written now
he was minor but AJ accurately Jair
Kohli wrote my dog tulip write wrote a
biography of his dog so and in Virginia
Woolf wrote a fictional biography of her
dog so I guess you can write about
anyone I have been thinking about since
our our amazingly enough is is nearly up
yeah I know we do talk on it's it's been
very entertaining I was thinking should
we have questions or should we what is
that sentence you quoted to me before
about when words when we've spoken
enough I was saying when people run out
of things to say they usually turn to
music because music is takes off where
words where words fail but
personally I think music would be
inappropriate at this time let me just
have a few questions you said it should
be spontaneous well all I will do is
illustrate a major theme of the book
which is that Beethoven as everybody
knows was deaf became deaf in his late
twenties began to become deaf and
suffered excruciating from tinnitus
through his thirties until he became so
deaf that the only way he could
communicate with him was to write
questions on paper now the confession
that he had tinnitus made me examine his
music to see if perhaps the pathology of
tinnitus the chiming the roarings the
buzzing in his ears might have somehow
come out to produce these very weird
sound effects you do get occasionally in
Beethoven frequently in Beethoven and I
talked about this to the American
Association of Neurological Surgeons in
New Orleans a couple of years ago and
happened to mention this idea of mine
and one of the neurologists got up and
said mr. Morris I have myself began to
lose my hearing and I'm studying the
phenomenon of deafness and he said I can
only tell you that the opening bars of
the Ninth Symphony led long sustain'd
hovering v that throbbing is exactly
what you hear when you're beginning to
lose your hearing so if you insist I
could demonstrate at least one passage
in there
it's from the rich Richie to teve at the
beginning of the slow movement of
Beethoven's piano sonata you know a flat
major opus 110
that a that reiterated a shrieks in his
music he uses do I think 75 times at the
finale of the Ninth Symphony I have no
proof of her but I'm quite sure that
derived from his tinnitus another
composer Friedrich Smetana actually
wrote a string quartet he also went deaf
in his late years in which in the last
movement it's suddenly interrupted by
this penetrating shrill high E which was
directly related to the sounds in his
head so it's a theory and what the hell
thank you all very much
wrapping up the author panel on
biography here at the 23rd annual Miami
Book Fair International live pictures
from the room in Chapman Hall on the
campus of miami-dade University
Christopher Hitchens a member of the
panel we live just heard from has been a
columnist at Vanity Fair the nation and
slate an occasional contributor to
several other publications he's attended
Cambridge and Oxford among his books
Thomas Jefferson author of America a
trial of Henry Kissinger and prepared
for the worst and edmund morris is best
known for his biographies of american
presidents his biography the rise of
Theodore Roosevelt won the Pulitzer
Prize an American Book Award in 1980 he
was for a short time President Reagan's
authorized biographer and published the
national bestseller Dutch a memoir of
Ronald Reagan in 1999 he has written on
travel and the arts for The New Yorker
the New York Times and Harper's Magazine
we are bringing you live coverage of
today's events all day here on book TV
and coming up shortly we'll take you to
an author panel on